Southeast Asian leaders meeting for a
second day of The asean Summit in the
Indonesian Capital Jakarta the ongoing
crisis in Myanmar and territorial
disputes in the South China Sea remain
high on the agenda asean leaders decided
on Tuesday that myanmar's military Junta
will not take over the group's rotating
leadership in 2026. they condemn
violence and attacks on civilians and
agreed that there had been little
progress on the five-point peace plan
the ten Nation Alliance has also split
on Russia's war in Ukraine let's go to
our correspondent Jessica Washington who
is live in Jakarta where the Summit is
being held so Jessica asyan is meeting
with China today what is expected to be
discussed
well in this dialogue between the
Chinese Premier Lee Chung and his asean
counterparts we don't know exactly what
has been discussed the meeting wrapped
up a short while ago but we did hear
some of the opening remarks now from the
premiere Lee Chiang we we heard him
speaking of the the Brilliance of the
relationship that asean shares with
China and the prospect of New
Opportunities I read some of what he
talked about that China asean
cooperation has come a long way and that
both share a Relentless pursuit of peace
and strong aspirations for development
and have a real commitment to the
stability of the region it's certainly a
relationship that has some high points
economic and trade ties China certainly
enjoys a relatively positive
relationship with asean but that's not
to say that there aren't these
difficulties as well these meetings are
taking place in just a few days after
China released what it calls a new
standard map laying claim to most of the
South China see of course that's caused
some agitation here in Southeast Asia
particularly for the Philippines
Malaysia and Vietnam
have they made any progress on the South
China Sea issue
certainly an issue that has plagued the
region for many years asean and China
have been discussing this code of
conduct for more than 20 years what we
do expect this week and what we have
heard is that Indonesia is pushing for
the asean leaders and for China to at
least agree to guidelines which would
not not actually be the code of conduct
itself but guidelines which would help
them hasten the process of negotiating
that code of conduct it's certainly the
most contentious issue if we're talking
about the relationship between many of
the Southeast Asian countries and China
and certainly one that has been in the
works for many years what we've seen
from the draft communique which does of
course talk about this issue is that
some of the asean members Express
concerns about land reclamations about
activities about serious incidents in
the area including actions that put
safety at risk that statement also says
that they recognize the need for new
initiatives with regards to this matter
so certainly not any specific mention of
what those initiatives might be but
definitely an acknowledgment from the
asean leaders that this is one of the
most contentious issues for the region
okay thank you for that Jessica
Washington there live for us in Jakarta